Film Courage: Did you see the movie THANK
YOU FOR SMOKING?
So Rob Lowe’s character [Jeff Megall, entertainment
executive] that’s what I envision is this
person.
Daniel Stamm: You know that in one minute
it doesn’t take long for the first meeting
because there are certain buzzwords that executives
I guess in their 20-minute story training
get told that if someone uses it that early
on in a conversation we are [BLEEP!].
Film Courage: I’m curious what those buzzwords
are?
Daniel Stamm, Filmmaker: You know one big
thing is “elevated genre, we want this to
be elevated.”
Sure?
What does that mean?
They want smart genre, the want blah, blah,
blah, blah.
Sure, but that doesn’t help us with the
development.
“Organic, the characters have to be organic.”
“It has to be character driven.”
It’s these words and they are all true but
there are clichés.
They came out of good observation so if someone’s
only contribution during the first meeting
is to ask for a character-driven elevated
horror story, I’m in trouble because it’s
not going to be much actual help coming from
that side.
Film Courage: With these catch phrases I hear
a lot of Millennials use the term “That’s
so meta!”
Or “It’s so epic.”
So those kind of buzzwords.
I’m still trying to wrap my head around
it.
I know what the word means but not in the
context of daily life, how is some experience
“so meta?”
I don’t know?
I’m showing my age with this statement.
Daniel: Right, you know that when you actually
ask someone to define that, there is “Well
you know.”
“No I don’t know.
What does that…how do you mean organic?”
And then you also get answers to certain buzzphrases
to questions like when you go “I think that
will be confusing.”
They will go “Oh, the audience today is
smarter than that.”
You can say that to every story problem “the
audience today is smarter than that.”
That is not an approach.
So when you get a series of those kinds of
things you kind of know that…yeah.